you know we asked her new new exciting
cast members that have joined and I
think we just confirmed that today that
Lupita that deny that night was a
surprise and Michael B Jordan excited
about all those actors I've known them
for quite some time and you know I think
we're putting together a great movie
with what we revealed today and other
things that you will you will see later
it's the first time I think I've been as
close to to the fans as this and seeing
people that are not just watching it
from afar but also they're they're a
part of it they're putting on the
costumes they're playing the characters
and they want to take a piece of the
story home with them whether it be a
signature like it's it's a lot of a lot
of good energy I think it feeds you as
an actor and as a filmmaker to go and
make the movie the best it could be so
they're sort of taking continue to have
that so I you know I appreciate it it's
the family I think I think I dig the one
thing I can say about about Marvel is
that they know what they're doing they
invite you in and make sure you have the
tools that are necessary to do what you
have to do and I just feel like it's
it's you feel like you're a part of
something way bigger than yourself which
is which is a great day and I think
they're doing right now they're at if
they're not ahead they're right on the
edge of what's going on as far as
storytelling so I love being a part of
that it's awesome it's amazing I'm still
pinching myself because I'm you know
there yesterday for the walking dead and
I never imagined I'd be able to
experience that type of elation twice in
one comic-con or twice ever you know so
it is really special really really
special to be a part of Marvel now and
to to have that experience that I just
had and see all the beautiful work and
all the amazing people it's it's kind of
overwhelming it's gorgeous I remember
like the first few times I came and it
really hit me you know because we come
here we're in the trenches like for The
Walking Dead and we're in the trenches
and you know we don't were very like
cloistered which is great but then when
we come here and we get all that fan
response it's like the call and the
response happens you know and you see
that there's all these people that are
receiving the work and allowing it to
live and that is such a beautiful thing
to have and to experience I love
comic-con that the joy the energy people
who are so all about this specific world
in this world so I think it's really
exciting it's amazing to join the Marvel
Cinematic Universe it's nothing I ever
imagined what happened for me and I'm
still kind of pinching myself about that
when I see I mean Marvel does the best
of the best in the best way you know
what I mean there's nothing like what
Marvel pulls off
you watch a cinematic portrayal of
superheroes flawed and struggling and
trying to get through the humanistic
storytelling combined with astounding
you know futuristic beautiful
supernatural superhuman ability hour and
and special effects out of the wazoo
it's just like it's thrilling to be a
part of that I still haven't quite wrap
my brain around it so I'm like now
you're kidding right kidding it's really
amazing it's the first introduction of
the cast yeah so on premiere was really
exciting because I can finally openly
confirm that I'm in the movie you know I
don't I haven't read the script I can't
tell you that much about the character
but extremely excited to be a part of
this project teaming up again with Ryan
Coogler you know working with Lupita and
Chadwick and I all incredible actors um
and yeah just super excited to be a part
of it I don't think it's anything like
it honestly comic-con the tastemakers of
anything sci-fi and fantasy fantastic
and marvelous like they are the ones if
you want to know if your property is hot
or if you got a good movie or a good
television short comic book or video
game or whatever it is you bring in here
and I'll kind of fill that energy from
from you know eleven thousand people
probably stayed the night in line to you
know to wake up in the morning and be
here that's dedication so we take this
is just a seriously they do so to be
able to like you know I feel inspired
and I think I want to go work
overwhelming now I mean we did our panel
and I sat down like in the crowd to
watch to watch the rest of stuff that
that that you guys had going man I mean
it was a notional cloud on cloud nine
man like you know it's not my first time
in Hall H last time I was here I was
just a fan you don't also to be able to
stand up on the stage shed credit was a
moment I'll take with me you don't need
forever you know it feels great man
about the same time it's a lot of work
to do it you know I mean I like to live
up to you know absolutely there's a lot
of people who have a lot in common you
know and um and it's all my favorite
actors in here I never had a chance to
meet you know it's really cool but at
the end of the day Venice it's
motivational you know I mean you went
you went an arm maybe one that you want
to
for lack of a better time y'all want to
dissapoint you know you want to make
something that that uh that keeps moving
the ball forward people were so excited
to see what Marvel has to offer us now
and it was very enthusiastic and I think
there was a lot of love you know people
really really looking forward to the
Black Panther among other things so it
was a very very warm welcome comic-con
has a reputation and it is a reputation
of being a group of people who really
are committed to their this this very
very rich world of make-believe and
during comic-con they can realize their
dreams of being these people and living
in those fictitious worlds that they
spend the rest of the year watching so
it's a it's a very liberating time it
feels when you look out the window you
see people dressed up in all sorts of
fabulous costumes and it's families that
are attracted to it and families that
participate and it's so nice to see
adults and children playing together I
just feel like Disney has been the gift
that just keeps on giving and I and all
the opportunities that I've had with the
studio have been so different
and now Marvel and Marvel is I mean I've
watched the Marvel films and I'm a fan
of the Marvel films
to think that somehow I am now on the
inside of it is is so cool yeah and I'm
just looking forward to actually doing
the work and bringing Wakanda to life
and and yeah I can't wait to actually do
it
you